[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by m Aaron and
Marguerite who star in Reginald the
vampire which premieres tomorrow night
10 pm Eastern on sci-fi how you guys
doing today good to see you thanks for
being here yeah no it's great to be with
you guys I absolutely love the show I'm
excited for people to see this cast
absolutely crush it now my first
question is for m m with the character
of Sarah what did you relate the most to
her about
okay I feel like I've gone I've given
this answer like a couple different ways
I I I I I really despise the fact that
I'm such a people pleaser I'm really
trying not to be because it's like you
know you want everyone around you to be
comfortable and happy and I think it
comes from a good place but also you
have to be authentic with how you feel
and who you are and validate yourself in
that way so I definitely identify with
the people-pleasing aspect
um and I think that
um Sarah throughout the season really
starts to stand on her own two feet
um and I mean I won't give too much away
but there are moments where I'm like I'm
freaking proud of you Sarah you told
them what was what and um I'm keeping
that with me because I'm trying to do
the same in my life too so yeah no I
love that answer and I love that the
character Sarah has like a nice mini Arc
throughout the season now Aaron is there
a sick thrill for you to playing the
bully character of Todd here
sick of sick girls yeah
uh no I mean it is it's a blast to play
in because even when you read the
scripts you're laughing out loud like
the absurdity of how
much of a dick is like you're like oh
man come on uh so when I was creating
Todd there was a level of
like yeah he's a dick he's a jerk but I
really wanted to like heighten it with
this level of dorkiness too like deep
down he's kind of just like
a loser too and that's why he feels this
need to like pick on reg because it's
like he's like they're actually he sees
a lot of himself in him probably yeah I
did really want to inject that a little
bit of he's just super insecure and I
mean most Bullies Are well all Bullies
Are but um yeah it was just so much fun
to be able to like have that uh level in
there as well yeah no Todd I like that I
like the Todd character has the layers
to it so it props to you Aaron and then
Marguerite your monotone fast delivery
of lines is amazing um what is your
Technique in memorizing lines and
getting down that delivery
um I use this great app called my
learner okay there there we go
[Music]
and I mutter like really disturbing
stuff to myself
because Ashley has like these kind of
like taken out of context like if you're
just a person walking around muttering
to yourself like Ashley's lines are a
little like off-putting so it's kind of
hilarious that I I feel like there I had
some I got some worried looks like on
the bus
I'm literally about to download that app
right now it looks so good and I'm in
yes I love it
um yeah no and the character of Ashley
is just so fun to watch and again
another character where the arc is just
great throughout the season so everybody
check out this awesome cast with M Aaron
and Marguerite in Reginald vampire which
appears tomorrow night 10 pm Eastern on
sci-fi thank you guys so much for
joining me and I'll talk to you in the
future one day thank you Steve thanks
guys